[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 188 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark merchandani and I'm here with
my colleague Brian Dorsey hey Brian
hello and we've got a really good
conversation here today with Priyanka
about conversational AI kind of matter
oh it's super super cool but before we
get into that we also have our question
of the week which talks a little bit
more about running Python scripts or
really any other script in a very
recurring manner awesome
but before even we get into that I like
all these before it's very confusing
about where we are the show as though
people hadn't realized what the
structure was well before we do that we
do want to talk about our cool things of
the week
[Applause]
so I work in Cerberus and compute for
developers in general and you know we
mostly focus on like trying to make it
easy and smooth and reliable to run
stuff but we also need to keep it secure
and so there was an article on the geez
people recently on how to execute the
principle of least privilege when
building a system and cloud functions so
I just want to plug that a little bit I
think it's pretty interesting and at the
core it's basically using a service
account dedicated for each function and
then giving it specific permissions on
your project yeah I mean these resources
are easy to spin up and easy to manage
so it kind of makes sense that you might
create an individual service account for
each function and then be really really
granular about the permissions those
accounts have and this is a relatively
new feature for functions but it is
definitely there now so it used to be
the case that like all functions render
one service account and so now you can
make much more granular controls and
we've got a link to introducing it and
going into more detail in the notes
and speaking of using functions to do
kind of cool things there's a fantastic
blog post that I just saw about spinning
up a minecraft server using functions to
send the triggers right for starting and
stopping the server using compute engine
to host the actual server and using some
backups but I think what makes this
really really cool is that this little
blog post is targeted towards like
having a child start to understand some
of these architecture pieces and you
know maybe as parent-child thing you can
both work on it and kind of spin up a
minecraft server which i think is super
fun because you know we've seen a lot of
examples of previous architectures
involving Minecraft in the past but this
is a fun way that you can kind of take
something that most kids care a lot
about which is Minecraft and try to get
into showing them the architecture
version and it even has like a fun
little child architecture diagram which
I completely adore but it's a very cute
and very fun way to showcase a simple
architecture and then it gives you a lot
of ideas of what you might build on top
of that for example a common one is you
know how do you make sure that there's a
sort of a cure for you setup so that the
server shuts down well again that's
something you can do with functions
that's super interesting and I think
applicable to a lot of kind of work
environments as well so that's a lot of
fun actually that reminds me I think
several years ago a colleague of ours
Julia Fraley wrote
series of posts about container izing
minecraft and running it on google
kubernetes engine so let's include a
link to that too so that might be like
the the next step after a compute engine
is you teach your child containers and
then and then show the minecraft in that
you could never start too early i you
can and i would not want to be the
person teaching containers to a middle
school group but you know what actually
i think a lot of people on our team are
doing that and props to them and i think
me you know what maybe you're right
maybe you can't start too early and they
get these concepts a lot faster than i
did that's super fun okay so another
cool thing that we cuz i think is
keeping in tune with the overall theme
for our main topic is around AI and we
just recently announced a what if tool
for cloud AI platform models so there's
this on running understanding that one
of the challenges for working with ml is
actually understanding what's going on
in the covers and how the models making
decisions so there's this tool what if
that has worked with tensorflow and now
works with few other very common ml
backends and works with air platforms
are running on GC p or on your own
machines to help you understand how the
model is making its decisions so it lets
you kind of investigate i guess by the
name what if you were to change some
certain aspects of it or how you can
kind of look at it from a more holistic
view and kind of ask more intelligent
questions is that right yeah exactly
that and you know for example kind of
give you visualization of the
distribution of where things land and
when you click there you can see where
the model made a different decision for
similar cases so you can really get down
at the details of why something turns
out a certain way or not and help the
model from there well i can definitely
say that i would rather teach a large
class about containers than i would
about AI as a person coming from compute
perspective i would be a lot more
successful that way as well all of those
words i just said were from the blog
post that is linked in the show notes so
that is it time to get into it I think
we should let's go ahead and jump into
our interview with Priyanka
[Music]
okay here we are I'm Brian Dorsey here
today with mark and Priyanka for gaudiya
I go ahead can you introduce yourself
and what do you do sure yes so I am a
developer advocate at Google cloud and
I've been working with customers and
partners on conversation AI use cases
for quite some time so I'm really
excited to be here it's a conversational
AI what is that conversationally AI or
conversational experiences it's
basically a comprehensive name for a
newer class of solutions that include
chat BOTS
voice BOTS experiences that are
basically conversational based so
whether it's an apps or messengers and
things like that the common denominator
is basically the use of natural language
understanding and natural language
processing which is obviously a type of
AI technology to power these
interactions between humans and and
machines so let's let's take it a step
back there tell us what natural language
understanding really means absolutely so
in very simplistic terms natural
language understanding is a technology
that helps translate human language into
computer language and also vice versa so
let's think about this as an example so
when you and I when two humans are
talking to each other and if we speak in
the same language we don't need a
translator but if I speak English and
you speak say Spanish and I don't
understand Spanish and vice versa then
we need a translator in the middle to
translate my English to Spanish and then
your Spanish to English same way when
humans are talking that human language
needs to be translated to a computer
because computer speaks binary zeros and
ones right so our English needs to
translate into those zeros and ones and
then computer responds back then that
binary needs to be translated back into
English as well so that technology can
be called natural language understanding
and then while we are at it natural
language processing is also worth
mentioning right because natural
language processing is a superset of
this realm very rational anguish
understanding falls in it and natural
image processing in
pollutes things like how do you
paraphrase something or how do you
summarize a given story or how do you
understand sentiments off of a
conversation or was there a spelling
mistake or an error or accent changes
and differences and things like that so
that is what natural language
understanding and processing means and
it's kind of the core of conversational
er technology okay so this is more than
just like speech to text then yes it's
absolutely much more than speech to text
like I said when you talk about natural
language processing speech to text is
like one part of it there is natural
language understanding which is the
other part and then you hear things like
text-to-speech is another part of it and
then you'll also hear automatic speech
recognition which is ASR so these are
kind of like different parts of the
technology that fall under natural
language processing so we've got a way
for people to talk and understand what
they're saying and that's kind of one
side of it but then you dive deeper into
it right with things like sentiment and
understanding what they're saying even
going so far as to summarize what
they're saying because you're able to
pull out these very abstract concepts
and then define them and say I think
when this person mentions something
about the Eiffel Tower for instance I
know what that is I know where it is I
know it's this landmark and then I can
use that information to pull together
something else whatever that workflow by
be going back to what you were saying
earlier about chatbots right I mean on a
website usually there's a pop-up or
something and then you can kind of
converse with in this case an AI so this
is something new or interesting I mean
we've been talking about you know kind
of robo chat for a while but this is
more about actual AI why is this big and
what's happening now that's making this
more prevalent than it used to be the
one that we are living in now with more
and more devices that are coming online
these days whether it's IOT or just our
preference of dealing with more devices
and working with more devices take an
example you know you wake up in the
morning starting from a smart coffee
maker - like when you end your day with
asking Google to set your alarm you deal
with so many
vices in the day and it's going to be
and it's already is becoming really
difficult to deal with all the devices
and work with them on a smart screen we
are going to have to have conversations
with our machines and devices as we
progress in this era where we have more
and more devices just an example right
when you're having breakfast or cooking
breakfast and then and you want to know
what's the traffic like to the office
you don't want to look at a screen you
just want to know the answer to that so
that's just one example but that goes to
say that we are moving in the era we're
dealing with machines is becoming our
everyday pattern and every minute
pattern and for those reasons most
people are interested in having their
problems solved with wise and
conversational interfaces so this is
showing up in a bunch of place so you
mentioned chat BOTS and we've got these
kind of like the boxes you see on
support for like websites they talk to
maybe a home or other assistant thing in
the morning for weather in traffic and
such are these the most common use cases
or there's other things what are people
actually doing with this today and what
do you see them doing next yeah I saw I
just gave like the broad examples with
the traffic pattern and alarms and such
and smart coffee makers but word
companies or enterprises are using
conversational AI for our use cases
around customer experience and customer
support and it's very easy to start with
that use case it's because of the fact
that you know a very specific pattern of
questions that your customers would ask
or your users would ask so it's a lowest
barrier to entry into conversational AI
and examples could include like for
example if you talk about retail that
customer experience could be a personal
shopper where I want to know a specific
type of outerwear I'm looking for and
then this personal shopper can give me
recommendations on here are some of the
different sizes and colors and party
bears versus others and things like that
and I actually built a demo around that
a few weeks ago and then the other
example could be in banking or in
financial institutions where really when
you go to a teller you ask questions
like what's my balance or I want to
withdraw
an amount or I want to transfer an
amount from this account to this account
and you can do all of that
through chat or a conversational
experience so those are some of the easy
waste can I get into it and also the
best place to start because you know
what the users asking for and you know
how to respond to it because your
backends are already supporting that
with your websites or in a more
personalized manner so you can put those
two together into a conversational
experience by using a natural language
understanding or processing platform
like the one we're going to talk about
which is dialog flowing don't worry
we'll mention dialog flow for you but I
wanted to pick up on some of the topics
you were saying there I mean with
customer support being probably one of
the premier examples of this and
basically just taking that conversation
piece and automating it right because
there's a huge subset of the users that
call in or they contact support and I'm
sure there's some percentage out there
I'll make one up and say 98% can be
solved through like routing it through
like three simple kind of formula
questions that are FA cues or what have
you but then the people who do kind of
get through that and when they do get to
usually a live human agent though at
least have a little bit more information
on what the context is so there's this
great kind of balance between not having
to be on hold as long because you want
to wait for a person many people can
interface with the Machine at the same
time and not have to overload it but
we've seen implementations of these
things for a long time right I mean the
automated phone support system has been
around for quite a while and I speak for
myself and maybe popular media when we
say like oh these are so frustrating
sometimes and they're so rigid and
you're just like I want to check out you
know I need this piece of information
but the Machine won't let me have it or
it needs these 80 things that it's not
related it's very cool it's very
interesting but it can also be
incredibly frustrating I would hope that
a lot of this stuff is changing it but
you know I'm sure there's been lots of
failure cases as well where does the
challenge lie in this where do the
problems happen yeah I think so the
biggest thing that needs to be thought
about or why conversational interfaces
had have failed or do actually fail even
today there is a really good compiled
list but chat bots start fail and
it's definitely worth checking out but
I'm gonna highlight a few here some of
the reasons why chat BOTS
actually fail is the rigid structure
right the flowcharts or they're really
designed for how the machine responds
and what the machines looking for not
how a human would say something and that
is where the biggest problem is so what
we need to do in order to create a good
natural experience is to use natural
language obviously natural language
understanding and processing where you
can have the Machine understand what the
users saying and then decide what needs
to be done versus in the IVR examples
that are frustrating that you mentioned
mark we went the other way around right
we are basically designing an IVR by
saying ok I will only take a customer
account information and if they don't
give me the account information I'm
going to keep saying can you say that
again can you fake that again and that
is what makes it frustrating because
there is no understanding that the
customer doesn't have so I can ask for
these other things I'll give you a very
simple example where if I say would you
like coffee and the IVR is expecting yes
or no and if I said sure it's gone it's
gone wild because it doesn't know that
sure also means say yes I gotta be
honest in the mornings when I need
coffee even yes or no is asking a lie if
I could just kind of unintelligently
grunt towards it and it's like yeah he
needs to come that would be for her
exactly so that's what I'm alluding to
and that's the advancement in technology
that we are utilizing with natural
language understanding and processing so
that's definitely one and then some of
the others are you need to make sure
that your back end is actually properly
integrated with your front end so you
can have the very best natural language
understanding experience but if your
back ends your databases cannot connect
properly to respond to these questions
then again that experience is not going
to be useful so in this case let's take
an example and say you connect to
Salesforce back
where you create these tickets or
questions that the user comes with and
you create a case in Salesforce but the
hook or the API that needs to make that
connection is either not live or you
don't have the right way of making that
connection then it's not going to be a
really good and streamlined experience
so making sure that the backend can
connect is another very big example and
then some others could be creating a
chat bot that is a silo right and it
only does this one thing and doesn't do
the other five things that it should be
doing so if somebody asks a question
about the other five things that are not
handled then how do you handle them in
that but it's okay to not have them
handled but not have the answers to
those questions but it's it's not okay
to leave the user thinking what they are
supposed to do so you need to provide
them something to go off of I have a
related question around this exact thing
so if we think about GUI versus command
line you know we kind of think that the
visual user inpatients are kind of more
discoverable you can kind of figure out
what's possible or not but you have to
do the same thing every time and command
lines you know it's not as easy to
figure out what's possible but once you
do you kind of internalize that and you
can do things very quickly or you can
make scripts to do things in order and I
feel like we're almost missing like how
to think about these things and in
particular yeah for voice as a user I
find this question of like not even
knowing what's possible really
challenging like I don't know what I can
say or not say to the thing I'm talking
to you and it gets frustrating after a
while as people are interested in
designing these do you have
recommendations for how to help with
that challenge yes so the first biggest
recommendation that we offer when we it
help design these experiences is then
the user ends up on your body experience
or in your chat experience however they
are ending up on that landing prompt
that prompt should be very specific in
terms of what this bot can do so when I
have when my bod responds back saying hi
welcome to XYZ I can help you get your
balance information and transfer funds
from one account to another and if it
does only these two things then mention
those two things if there's any other
question
that they have at least a user now knows
that the bot can do these two things is
this like the rest of life like setting
expectations is everything exactly right
just make sure that you're setting those
expectations correctly and obviously
they're going to ask questions that you
didn't expect them to ask and then for
those you have the fallback mechanism
where you say okay I didn't understand
that but a connection to a human being
or a live agent is also very critical
there are going to be scenarios where
your bot will not know what to do
because it's not programmed to do that
in those cases how do you connect to a
live agent whether it's chat or a call
is important and you need to figure that
out as well while you're building the
bot yeah I mean for command lines we've
got like tactic help right so usually
you have this verbose list of all the
things you can do but in conversing with
AI it doesn't exist is that something
that see people have tried and it just
didn't work is that something that just
doesn't resonate with people I had a
conversation with one of our voice user
interface designers at Google a few days
ago and she brought up a very
interesting point she said we all assume
that we know how to have a conversation
and that's why we start building a bot
without creating any blueprints and that
is the biggest problem and she kept
mentioning and highlighting the fact
that you need to build the design flows
they're not flowcharts they are the
flows where you say here are the
thousand ways in which people can ask
for coffee and understandable right that
machine learn is going to handle all
those thousand ways but you still need
to think how the flow would Traverse
when they're asking for coffee in
different ways and conceptualizing and
visualizing that flow is really critical
so she recommended that anybody who
starts designing a bot do not start
designing it without having a blueprint
of what you're designing for here are
the four things I'm designing for and
then these four flows can look something
like this and that is very important to
have and I think that's the part we keep
missing because we think that we know
how to have a conversation and this is
what people are going to ask my body and
we just end up developing I'm super new
to this when you say like design these
blueprints I don't know what that
actually is or looks like because I used
to you know either code or scripts or
you know HTML or something what's the
format of these blueprints is it just
drawing things out so you have a good
sense your head or what does it look
like and I ask the same question right
because we are mostly developer-centric
people so we think about codes and
strips and for charts things like that
and she literally said it can be any
format that you want it to be in it can
be just a simple script where it's like
the user is going to say this and the
bot is going to respond with this and
the bot can respond in these four ways
if the user says this question in these
different ways so it can literally be
any format you prefer it can be an excel
sheet it can be just a word dog it could
be an animated format with pictures and
stuff but the idea is that you should
have something to go off of and not just
start coding this is gonna make it super
awkward the next time I run into Brian
in the hallway and I'm gonna be like
hold on let me bust up my spreadsheet
because I need to map out this
conversation well yeah do you put that
amount of preparation in because I
promise you I am now self-conscious
about being able to have a conversation
Frank is like most of us don't know how
to have conversations of like yeah of
course
why else would I host a podcast I have
no idea how to have a conversation but
what you're saying is we need some sort
of flow of dialogues perhaps in the form
of a dialogue flow exactly would you
like that lead-in by the way I thought
it was gold working on it for like three
days so tell us a little bit more about
what dialogue flow actually is dialogue
flow is Google's tool that is powered by
natural language understanding and
natural language processing to create
rich and natural conversations and what
I mean by that is it makes this process
simpler and easier when I said I can ask
for coffee and thousand different ways
depending on the day and the mood and
the time and all of that right it's
nearly impossible to get
there all of those ways in which
thousand people are going to ask for
coffee but in a broader term it's easy
to just lay it out and what dialogue
flow does is you put an intent in seeing
most common ways in which people ask for
coffee and then it would apply the
natural language understanding and NLP
on it and comprehend some of the other
ways in which people can actually ask
for coffee so I can say I would like
some coffee and I can give like 10
examples in there and say I would like
some coffee can I get some coffee it
would be great to get some coffee right
now amazing to get some coffee right now
ah coffee sounds amazing right these are
some ways in which I ask for coffee
depending on what the day is and what my
mood is I'm pretty sure Marc has some
very interesting ways I mean you're very
polite to your coffee maker feel bad I
usually just yell coffee at mine and
it's not voice enabled I just am yelling
coffee while also wanting with deep
apologies to everyone listening to this
before they've had their confidence ya
know I mean if you haven't had your
coffee please pause go grab some ideally
while yelling the word coffee and then
come back to us the power of dialog flow
is you provide these intense and then it
would map some of the others on its own
because it's powered with natural
language processing and understanding it
would understand the other ways in which
people are asking for coffee so you
don't have to provide those thousand
examples you can just provide a few and
it still understands the users intent so
that's one and then the other power of
dialog flow is you design your part
experience once and you can enable it
for multiple different interfaces and
that is the biggest thing because
omni-channel is a huge requirement for
enterprises because you want to make
sure that the experience of the brand is
similar on every channel that the users
interacting you with so whether they're
coming from Facebook Messenger or slack
or Google home or existant or just a web
chat the experience should be seamless
and similar a
across the board so that's the other
power that you get from dialog flow
there's also languages right so it's not
that you're only going to support
English or one language in which you're
doing business today you have to think
about global expansion and have multiple
languages supported so if you're doing
it by yourself it's going to be really
hard to support all these different
languages dialog flow comes already with
20 languages and we keep adding the
support based on our text-to-speech and
speech-to-text offerings so that is
again very powerful and then it comes
with analytics and that's always very
useful the other a very important aspect
is small talk and the pre-built agent so
small talk is as you can imagine like
what's the weather like
it comes with pre-built small talk so
that you can just plug the small talk
portions and intense into your bot
experience so you don't have to think
about all the ways in which people do
small talks really chatty chat BOTS
exactly do people respond well to the
small talk e4 chat BOTS um it depends it
depends on what the persona of your bot
is and that is HUGE topic around persona
of the body and you kind of define that
before you start building your bot
whether your body is gonna be Kiki or
chatty or serious and once you define
that persona you know it might sometimes
make sense to have small talk experience
in there it usually makes it a little
bit more chatty but more friendly we
make a bot that only the small talk
welcome home
there's been a war isn't there you've
certainly changed okay so I'm inspired
to kind of play with this and and see
like some sort of coffee experiments
with BOTS and I'm sure other folks
listening are also kind of interested in
digging in here how would you recommend
people get started like learn more about
this yeah so multiple different ways and
avenues to get started the first is
definitely some documentation that we
have on www.osho.com/copyright osho
the series of videos that I've started
from basically 101 called deconstructing
chatbots
it is on our YouTube channel Google
Cloud YouTube channel there you can
actually get started from like what is a
button how do I design one to actually
building one by yourself and then there
are labs that are in there as well that
you can follow along that point you to
code labs and then the series is ongoing
so you can catch up and get to a point
where you can start to build not just
basic conversations but also interact
with more Google Cloud machine learning
content so the episode that comes out I
think in the next two weeks or so is
actually building a bot to understand
invoices when a user uploads their bill
it's interesting and you can create
these while you are working through
videos along with me and you get the
positive Orion links as well so I would
say that's a good way to start I foresee
Brian in the next couple of weeks making
small talk with his coffee pod
I'm just gonna try to see if I can get
it all the way to grunt equals coffee in
my case if I'm honest it's gonna be hot
tea oh well I mean that's that's you
know that usually serves a similar
purpose
oh I mean if I get up and I'm just like
yeah I want that cup of coffee right
there ready for me we may have
discovered a deep deep fundamental
philosophical difference well with the
power of dialog flow I'm sure you can
generalize it to say like hey I want my
breakfast drink and then the AI will
know there we go that yeah so I think
we're just about out of time Priyanka is
there anything else you want to mention
I mean we'll have a link to the
deconstructing chat box playlist in the
description below the show but is there
anything else you want to mention before
we head out I would just say that these
are really easy to build experiences so
give it a shot just like Brian is going
to in the next few weeks I'm signed up
okay
everyone please give it a go and thank
you very much for your time for yoga
Thanks thank you okay that was a great
conversation
with Priyanka you know I've played
around with a few of these things
thankfully she's got that deconstructing
chatbots playlist so I followed that and
there's some code labs on there as well
that have kind of helped me play with it
but there's a lot of aspects to really
thinking about how people engage with
chat pots and you know what modeling
that looks like I keep coming back to
all the different places where you can
interact with the same back-end that you
build once so that just seems really
powerful as somebody who's used to
having to kind of write different
versions for every new kind of front-end
that might show up yeah much more
flexible and a cool way to think about
creating a system like you said and then
reaching all these different end points
which is great to meet users in a lot of
different ways yep meet people where
they are
speaking of meeting people where they
are we also have a really cool way that
I think will help a lot of people run
some more very common tasks in the cloud
and the question is if I have a script
like for instance a Python script how do
I run it in an automated fashion right
like a recurring script whether it's
every morning three times a day how do I
do that in the cloud oh right so like
the kind of thing for all like on a
Linux box you might use like the cron
script scheduler for like hey every
third hour call this thing right I mean
you could spin up a compute engine and
then put crowd on there but then you've
got to worry about what happens if
someone wants to shut the Box down or
you're wasting resources I mean that
doesn't seem like a very scalable way to
do it who schedules the schedulers
there's a terrible terrible superhero
out there that I'm sure I don't think
Kron Man is a very good but you know
what he's always on time okay let's move
to the meat of this what is the
recommendation in this vlog well I think
that the question is you know using this
Python script how do I run it and it
looks like if we run this with functions
we've got some options to use both cloud
scheduler and pub/sub but can you tell
me a little bit more about how cloud
scheduler works cool okay yeah this
article is written by Caitlin Ardath
who's one of our strategic cloud
engineers and it's really basically
saying you cloud scheduler handles the
scheduling part of it so that like a
task happens on a regular basis and
functions is the thing we want to run in
this case and using pub/sub our
messaging queue that's both high
throughput and very durable including
retries and things like that so it
doesn't get lost if the function has an
error or something like that and so you
use pub/sub is the kind of connection
between the two which is a really
powerful model for distributed systems
in general you've got a thing that is in
charge of policy a thing that is in
charge of making sure that like it
happens at least once and then the thing
that does it seems like a really great
set up so it's a very nice succinct walk
through of this pattern that is really
common exactly right it gives this
example using specifically a Python
script that runs bigquery but at the
same time you've got your manage cron
you've got a flexible events handling
system and then you can pretty much do
whatever you want to do on the actual
execution side so this is a really
starter architecture that can go out in
a lot of different ways in this case
they're using pub/sub but you know you
could also have used HTTP for the
functions but I think that
authentication will be a lot harder for
that right it is now supported in both
scheduler and functions to use the new
basically a service account
you get the token from the environment
and kind of pass that through the HTP
but I think that going through pub/sub
is a much more general pattern and I
think it lets you plug other things in
like in this case like maybe you're not
going to necessarily do things off the
same policy of like every other hour or
twice a day or something maybe you are
and then you can add additional things
kind of listening to that same you know
pub/sub event
yeah very flexible in a good way to
start working on something in the first
time you build it you might be saying
well I don't know if I need all these
pieces right why not just keep it very
very simple but as you extend outwards I
think you're gonna find that having
built it in this flexible way is gonna
make it a lot easier down the road I
kind of alluded to it at the beginning
there's some obvious stuff that's great
you know if you have a direct call and
for some reason there's a timeout or
something goes wrong that's a temporary
error if you're making the direct call
it'll never happen again if you're
working off of a hewing system and
actually kind of responding to those
directly it'll make sure that it retries
it you know after failure doesn't like
very cool so all those details are in
the blog post well before you wrap up
here Brian what are you doing where you
go and do any fun travels so actually
I'm based in Seattle and I'm gonna be
spending the next while kind of hanging
out here in the office thinking about
compute engine it's just just kind of
sitting and meditating on compute engine
[Music]
that a slice of a computer I slice with
data center oh no wait no no those are
deep questions too much too much oh well
I'll be traveling to Austin next week
to record with a customer hopefully
which will be a podcast not too far from
now sticking around the Bay Area to work
on some up-and-coming training videos
which I think will be or the subject
matter there I'm super helpful I know I
can't say like what it is until it's out
so I'm always like oh I want to talk
about it but I kind of can't but looking
forward to as always creating some
really fun content awesome well thanks
for hanging out with us all the way to
the end everyone very very cool and
we'll see you all next week
[Music]